welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this video will
be giving our thoughts on how the third
season of Westworld should have ended
now up top I will be saying that I
really enjoyed the show and this isn't
going to be made in a way to say the
writers did a bad job shows should
always give you what you need instead of
what you want but it's still fun to use
our imaginations so let's view this as
one possible scenario in Rehoboth world
in which we the fans get to give off
feelings on how the show should have
ended obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you still haven't
seen the third season yet then I highly
recommend that you turn yourself offline
and go and check out the show make sure
you subscribe to the channel for videos
like this every day and please drop a
thumbs up if you enjoy it without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of how Wes
world should have ended okay so in order
to talk about how we would have liked to
have seen the season end we have to go
back to the start and talk about the
serac brothers after seeing their home
destroyed the pair decided that they had
to save humanity from itself and thus
they built Rehoboam using Liam Dempsey
seniors money they bought data from the
owner of Delos aka William and were able
to create an algorithm that charted a
course for every person on the planet
however they ran into a snag at a
certain point humanity would come to an
end no matter what simulation they ran
this always happened and the final
moment that they were able to trace it
back to you was the rise of the hosts in
Westworld the algorithm predicted that
the first host would escape the park and
through using human would bring
civilization crashing down there was
absolutely no way to get around this no
matter what preventative measures they
put in place
dolorous and this unknown person would
completely destroy the human race to
make matters worse due to the radiation
that they suffered at the hands of
seeing their home destroyed the two were
living on borrowed time we could see in
the flashbacks that the radiation
surrounding the fields of Paris was
enough to kill a cow there and those on
me was able to be fixed ignorin was
living on borrowed time it seemed like
neither would be able to save humanity
so they enacted a plan a little
experiment if you will in order to stop
this identifying his brother as an
outlier egg neuron decided to use his AR
technology to wipe his memory and give
him a new identity we did see in his
reeducation centers that those
identified his search were given
completely new backstories and shipped
off to the army serac found the perfect
fit who completely lined up with this a
soldier that had been killed in Crimea
whose mother had schizophrenia serac
took this man's life and memories
implanted them within his brother and
then completed reconstructive surgery on
him so that facial recognition software
would not recognize him this was
something that was now prevalent
throughout the world due to technology
and serac needed to put this in place to
make sure his brother was never found
so rax plan was to place his brother as
the savior of humanity so that when it
came down to it he could be woken up and
defeat Dolores before she could enact
her plan serac gave him the identity of
Caleb Nichols and sent his brother off
on a path that would lead to him being
at the forefront of the hosts uprising
Caleb was a spy in the Bible and he to
his brothers fascination with Solomon
Rehoboam
and stories of that nature it seemed
like the perfect fit yes we're doing the
caleb is sir axe brother theory but bear
with me the new life was reinforced
within John me through a program known
as Francis who is a friend of the
real-life Caleb and Caleb's mother
though she knew something was off with a
son was ignored due to her mental
illness she on Me 2 possessed
schizophrenia so should it develop
within him it would merely be seen as
being hereditary serac succumb to his
radiation poisoning but he was able to
upload his consciousness into Rehoboam
which through the use of hologram made
it seem as if the character was still
alive I know I know this is kind of
cliche but I did feel like the finale
kind of robbed him of his cool factor
mainly because it relegated him to being
a puppet I didn't like it when they did
this to Bane or Snoke in Star Wars so
yeah please
let me keep this cool guy as a villain
even though he's a hologram and I do
prefer the way that he would actually be
Rehoboam in my imagining anyway he was
able to fool the world and those around
him using simulations something that he
could create without those knowing that
they were part of one this is when we
catch up to the start of season
and which dolores escapes the park and
then using copies of herself she
infiltrates all aspects of society the
Heil copy would still end up going rogue
and the key to the forge was always kept
with him Bernard Dolores believe that
Kaleb was an outlier that she could use
to bring down humanity and this tied
back to her speech on the Judas cow in
season 1 in the very first episode of
Westworld when Dolores and Teddy were
looking over cattle Teddy asked how they
managed to lead and hurt them Dolores
said that you had to pick a Judas cow to
lead them and that the rest would follow
in our imagining who planned the entire
time in season 3 tied back to this line
and she wished to choose a savior that
would lead humanity to the
slaughterhouse they would do this by
turning off Rehoboam and nurse when
humanity was left to their own devices
they would bring everything crashing
down
Dolores led Kaleb on a mission to
discover the truth of the Machine and
what serac had been up to things then
played out much in the same way that we
saw in the season up until they arrived
at the re-education Center serac knew
this would happen
so he set up a fake reveal for Kaleb in
which he would believe that he was an
outlier that had been used to kill other
outliers may have arrived to take
Dolores out but she managed to stop her
by using an EMP Kaleb then took a pill
to a backup body and a to set out to
destroy Rehoboam however upon arriving
at insight the AI God revealed its true
face and an earth that Kaleb was really
shown me this plan had been put in place
to stop Dolores dead in her tracks and
just as she reached Rehoboam so that
they could upload the forged data
directly into the machine
this would grant Rehoboam even more data
on human behavior and thus it would be
able to accurately predict everything
the reveal came as a huge blow to Kaleb
who realized he'd been living a lie this
entire time however Kaleb or rather she
on me had been given a new perspective
because he had seen how bad society
could be at the bottom he decided to go
against the original plan laid out by
his brother and he joined Dolores in a
mission to save humanity he freed her
from the Machine and thus unknowingly
doomed humanity to its fate fulfilling
the prophecy that Rehoboam had laid out
I don't know why but in time travel
stuff and things that involve
predictions I always love when people
try to prevent the future from happening
and in the end they're the
ones that cause it I would have loved to
have seen this in the show just to show
how accurate Rehoboam prediction really
was I think for me personally it would
have led to a more satisfying ending
anyway realizing that his brother was
dead and that their plan was folly he
ordered Rehoboam to shut down the
hologram of Sirach Delores said that
he'd saved the world and that he'd
stopped Rehoboam from gaining the data
just in time and that he truly was the
savior of humanity she promised that
using the data that only she had access
to they could plot out a strategy that
would allow hosts and humans to live
together this too however was all a ruse
and it was revealed to us that Delores
had not actually had the data she had
hidden it within Bernard who'd been
given a device that was able to access
the forge this would also put him into
hibernation so that he could wait out
the end of the world though he would not
know this before donning it she had kept
the key to all of this hidden away and
had used John me as a pawn though
everything didn't go according to plan
and the Jean me reveal was surprising to
her too
in the end she had got what she wanted
but what should they do now after all
they have this machine that can control
humanity well this is where the fifth
and final Dolores pill comes into play
throughout the season we saw that the
lorises plan was to replace high-ranking
members of society with duplicates and
this was carried out on a number of
levels
it was so engrained into her that even
hale carried this out on the man in
black and now in our little imagining I
would have loved to have had the season
end with Dolores revealing that her file
duplicate was actually serac before the
events of season three Ciroc had hidden
away from society purely because he no
longer existed however Dolores his plan
forced the hologram to emerge and
acquire Delos thus people now knew of
the character though they did not
realize he was a hologram
Dolores brought forth her final pill to
assume the position of the owner of
Delos she would now use him as the face
that she showed the world similar to her
Rehoboam had used him as its face this
would mean that their llores was now the
one secretly controlling Delos from the
shadows and she'd come full circle from
being a slave at the bottom within the
park to now being the company's ruler
using Caleb as a pawn
she'd set out on a path to destroy
humanity and had managed to achieve her
goal
I would have loved if the season had
have ended with us knowing that she
really was the villain and the tension
would come from wondering whether caleb
would discover this in any future
seasons thus we would end not knowing
where the humanity was really doomed
whether there was a way to stop Dolores
a host that now controlled bellows and
the machine that ruled over the species
I know it's very nihilistic I'm probably
not as nice as the slightly more
positive ending that we got but hey I
guess I'm a bad guy too and they've got
three more seasons to work this all out
in my imagining anyway now obviously I'd
loved hear your thoughts on our video
and if you would have liked you've seen
it or not I'm expecting people to just
say this is crappy fan fiction so if you
have your own ideas and what you would
have liked you've seen in the ending and
make sure you leave them in the comment
section below
you want to see our breakdown of what
really happened in the final episode
that makes you check out our video on it
which is going to be linked at the end
you want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
we massively appreciate you and there's
a thank you you get access to content
early you want to come check just after
the show in the follow us that
definition YT or click the discord link
in description below every month we give
away free movies to people are subscribe
to the channel and this month II could
win the Marvel phase 3 part 1 box set
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you sub with
notifications on the more videos you
comment on the more you have a chance of
winning so make sure you get involved
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of May and the set will be
shipped out from then - ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
you